there are the odds from points bet coach
of the year mike tomlin plus 175
i don't know that he's the favorite
right now guys when you look at those
odds the one that i would bet on without
question
kevin stefanski plus 900 give me 900 for
my 100
bet that's who i'd vote for that's who
deserves it no
off season program a team that's been in
turmoil they were 4 and 44
for crying out loud from 2015 through
2017. he has turned that team around
a year after the freddie kitchen's
debacle uh stefanski would get my vote i
think he should win it peter your
thoughts
you know i think it's really really
close right now i don't think you can
underestimate
where what ron rivera has done
especially
i'm glad these votes are taken at the
end of the year and not after 13 games
i think if rivera and washington win
the nfc east with at least an 8-8 record
i'd be inclined to vote for rivera but
i also i think stefanski's good i think
mcdermott is a great
uh candidate too yeah i i i think it's
the hardest year ever
you know at what point do we talk about
sean payton and the fact that he wins
without drew brees and just
they're the number one seed or the
number two seed every year when does he
get respect
you know the other one i'll say to you
guys too how come matt lafleur never
gets talked about in this conversation
you know mike mccarthy doesn't look all
that shiny he has aaron rodgers
i know but everybody that was a negative
when he got hired but now it went
good and everyone just goes ah so what
all right it's a negative i don't think
they'll get along and it's been
awesome ever since and everyone just
goes oh oh so it was awesome so
so we doubted him and he played since
matt lafleur since matt lafleur got this
job
only one coach in the nfl has a better
record and that's andy reid that that's
where i mean it just he gets totally
lost in the shuffle there
mike i agree with you i probably would
lean stefanski too but i think it's
really really close
and now let's not forget brian flores
what the he did
if ron rivera would win it that would be
his third
coach of the year award the others who
have won three or more
bill belichick chuck knox and don shula
the all-time leader
with four coach of the year awards
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports